[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another one of our live
sessions here at the world science
festival
a continuation of what initially began
as your daily equation
world science u world science festival
all blended
together today we'll do the usual have
some
q a for a little while and then we're
going to have a conversation
with a guest many of you know it's the
nobel laureate barry barish
nobel laureate whose contributions
made the first detection of
gravitational waves
possible so it's really exciting to to
talk
to barry i also wanted to note something
that
that i've seen in i don't study the
comments
be clear i just sort of glanced at them
on occasion but in the comments or the
chatter somewhere
i saw a number of people
when we were talking about black holes
obviously we were talking about that
because of the recent announcements in
nobel prize in physics
highly associated with
black holes you know the theoretical
side of the observational side but there
are a number of comments that said
black holes are nonsense this is
silliness
you know these scientists are talking
about something that's just
a fantasy of fiction and normally when i
see that kind of stuff i'm like
whatever and i'm pretty much that way
here too
but what's missing in that way of
looking at things
especially if someone doesn't know the
true scientific background of the story
is that
there was a time when that
might have been a reasonable perspective
but the success story of black holes
is one that we hold up as
a paradigm of how
we theorists envision our understanding
of the universe progression because look
let me just quickly take it through it
many of you are familiar with these
ideas but whatever let's just go through
it
1915 albert einstein writes down the
field equations of the general theory of
relativity
a couple years later carl schwarzschild
gets a hold of the manuscript finds the
first
exact solution of einstein's field
equations einstein himself
only had found approximate solutions to
the field equations okay
so that's a great achievement its own
right but within
the so-called schwarzschild solution you
can see the possibility
of black holes you can see that if
matter is crushed down to a
sufficiently small size then
the indentation in the fabric of space
will be so significant
that nothing will be able to resist
falling down that indentation
and by nothing i really mean nothing
nothing also includes
beams of light photons and if photons
can't climb out of this gravitational
well
then the region goes dark okay that was
all theoretical
right now einstein himself at that time
would have made a comment if youtube
existed
right or if these kinds of sessions
einstein if he deigned to participate i
don't think he would have
but he would have put a comment
something along the lines of yeah sure
the math says they exist but these
mathematically oriented scientists
are taking my mathematical equation a
schwarzschild solution to that
mathematical equation
they're taking it to an extreme that
doesn't exist in the real world
in fact einstein himself wrote papers
where he tried to
establish that black holes would not be
real they weren't called black holes
then but
this solution being pushed to that limit
where
you have gravitational implosion
gravitational collapse
einstein didn't think this would
actually be real in the universe this is
einstein saying that
okay so again that resonates with the
comments that i see
on on youtube or in wherever i was
seeing those comments okay good now but
that was
the 1930s and 1940s
it was a long time ago in the interim
people came up with
mechanisms by which gravitational
collapse
would happen stars use up their nuclear
fuel they can't support their mass they
implode inward okay
but beyond these abstract theoretical
ideas there are also observations that
began to take place right
so the nobel prize was awarded for
observations
of stars going around the center of our
milky way galaxy and being whipped
around at such incredibly high speeds
that the only candidate
for what could exert the powerful
gravitational pull
causing those stars to whip around the
center of the galaxy is an incredibly
massive
black hole in fact i think we may have a
visual if we can bring up the visual of
stars going around
the center of our milky way galaxy yeah
there you go right so
so here's the analysis
you measure the motion of stars
and you find that those stars you can
sort of see it here they're being
whipped around
right the center of our milky way galaxy
then you look closely to see what
is whipping them around and it's just so
compact it's so
dense it's so small yet exerting such a
gravitational powerful gravitational
pull
that it pretty much has to be a black
hole good okay so that is what was a
word of the nobel prize but even beyond
that
we have the event horizon telescope data
right can we bring up the image
of what the event you know there's a
black
hole right galaxy m87
54 55 million light years away this is a
black hole
whose light not from within the hole but
from the exterior
of the hole gas that surrounds the hole
heats up
emits radiation but you know
that's pretty much the most
straightforward demonstration
that these ideas are born out in the
world now look let me also emphasize
we don't know everything about black
holes black holes
are the theorists laboratory
par excellence right that is the domain
in which we push our understanding to
the limit
and our understanding of black holes is
today in flux there are questions about
black holes that we don't
fully know the answer to we don't fully
understand
necessarily what happens at the event
horizon at the edge of a black hole we
certainly do not
know what happens at the center of a
black hole
but that's the nature of research you
make theoretical headway
observation confirms your ideas and then
subjects them to further scrutiny you
make
further theoretical advances and on the
chain of reasoning ago so i'm not saying
that einstein's version of black holes
perhaps i shouldn't attribute it to
einstein
einstein's equations the version of
black hole that comes out of einstein's
equations we're still
in the process of fully understanding
what this monstrous
beast actually is but there can be no
doubt that something
very close to what we
call a black hole very close to the
phenomenon the features that we talk
about
there's a version of something like that
out there in the world it is no
longer science fiction no longer can a
rational person
not entertain this very real quality of
the world and what we'll be talking to
barry barish about today
is other evidence for black holes an
indirect signature coming from
black holes that are in binary pairs and
orbiting each other and colliding and
creating ripples in the fabric of space
gravitational waves
another independent piece of evidence
that these ideas
are correct so again i know that in some
sense i'm preaching to the converted
here
most of you are not skeptical in the way
that some
in the comments section are and i love
skepticism don't get me wrong
but skepticism has to be brought
up to be commensurate with what we know
or else it's just plain old ignorance i
don't mean that in a derogatory sense
but
to say things like i see written in the
comments is ignorant
okay it's not being an iconoclast
it's not somehow being
anti-establishment it's just being plain
silly and we see that kind of silliness
playing out
on the world stage a lot so when i see
it happen here i just
on occasion feel the need to to call it
out
all right so i hope that wasn't too much
of a rant for you guys if i was going to
rant further and something else i'd rant
on
in fact i'm going to rant on it for 30
seconds there was another person who
noted how
how you know in the conversation last
week with nobel laureate
harold varmus we spent a lot of time
talking about the coronavirus
and the pandemic and somebody wrote in
and said hey it was really interesting
conversation but
it was kind of discordant maybe that's
my word or theirs i don't recall
a little discordant to hear you talking
about the pandemic which you have
diligently avoided talking about for
seven months
and and oh sorry my phone is ringing
just sort of ignore that
but the point is i didn't diligently
avoid
the pandemic for seven months that's not
at all the case in fact if you go back
and look at the first
installment of your daily equation i
said there the reason why we're starting
the series is so that
those of you who are completely wrapped
up with the pandemic
might have something else to distract
you might have an
outlet to think about things that
perhaps are a little transcendent
relative to
the difficult times that we are
experiencing
here as a species on planet earth
and so the point of not dwelling on the
pandemic
in these sessions in your daily equation
and so forth was not to avoid
it rather it was to provide a respite
from it which is a very different
motivation so anybody you want to talk
about the pandemic
bring it up in the question session many
of us though
enjoy talking about the larger issues of
space
time gravity black holes and so forth
and that's the reason why the pandemic
hasn't
had a major footprint until last week in
our conversation we weren't avoiding it
it was just a choice to let the mind
free itself from the troubles and
travails that
we experience in a moment-to-moment
basis and fly out to the cosmos
anyway okay with that out of the way
let's now look at some of the questions
and about 3
30 or so we will bring in
barry bear although i just realized
something you know i had to move my
computer because
the lighting was so bad with the sun
coming in and i
am down to 13 10 percent
and i therefore i'm going to take half a
second here guys
to try and find a power cord
and this is going to require that i get
up and move around
a little bit so don't go anywhere this
is this last
minute change that we made and the one
wire that we forgot to move and plug in
is the power
got the internet got the microphone got
everything of that sort
so hang on half a second i'll be right
back
all right power cord
all right i got the power cord
sorry about that we are usually far
better prepared
but the sun made an unexpected
appearance
it was overcast and then the sun decided
to come
in and spoil the beautiful setup that we
had
so i had to move and let me just see if
i can figure out how to plug a plug in
in real time with you all watching me
okay that is good and with this we
should be all set
all right with any luck we'll hear that
wonderful little ding
oh god just barely did it with two
percent to go i hope i do not lose you
guys
i'm gonna take down power and everything
else to try to make it build back
up okay good all right sorry for
that little kerfuffle there
but let's uh let's take a look at what
the questions have here okay
galot asks can entanglement measure two
spin
components so
when you have an entangled pair of
particles their spins
are correlated with one another and so
when you measure the component of the
spin of one particle over here
say find it spinning up you measure the
effectively the other component must be
spinning down if they're in a so-called
spin zero state where they're
anti-correlated
against one another but you can't
measure incompatible observables
you can't measure components of the spin
that are mutually incompatible in the
sense that their
observables don't commute with one
another
and so you can't somehow do an end run
around the dictate of quantum mechanics
so there are certain quantities of the
world that you can't know simultaneously
so the uncertainty principle we normally
think about it is saying that you can't
know the position and the speed the
position and the momentum of a particle
simultaneously
but it also tells us that you can't know
the x component and the y component of a
spin
simultaneously either incompatible
observables
they don't commute with one another so
you can't if that was the
point of the question that you cannot
end run around that kind of quantum
uncertainty uh the knowledge asks when
will our sun
become a black hole answer to that is
it's
likely more than certain that our sun
will never become
a black hole in the sense that
the life cycle of a star
whose mass is comparable to that of our
sun
involves the sun ultimately using up
all of its hydrogen transitioning to
helium
the sun will swell and so on it will
become a couple hundred times its
current size in the process
it'll then fall back down it'll
use its helium for as long as it can but
ultimately our sun will transition into
a white dwarf it will not have
the process by which it would turn into
a black hole it need to be heavier
so if the sun was say 10 times its
current mass
then the likely scenario for the life
cycle would indeed
involve the sun undergoing
a kind of supernova explosion toward the
end of its life blowing out of its
surface and the remaining core would not
have any ability to withstand
the remaining residual mass and that
would collapse all the way down into
a black hole so it's not that every star
turns into a black hole at the end of
its life
many will but it depends sensitively on
the mass
of the object now if you're willing to
wait even longer than say the life
cycle of a star in the end
all matter we anticipate being sucked
into black holes and i'm now talking
about not on the order of billions of
years but i'm
on the order of 10 to the 100 years 10
to the 200 years if you're willing to
talk about those time scales
then you can imagine that our son merges
falls into a black hole in that way
becomes part of a black hole but i
suspect that was not
the intent of the question
all right i guys i am worried here that
i am at one percent
power let's hope that
i do not go down to zero which is an
unfortunate number when you're looking
at the residual
power on your screen i wonder if i'm
having an electrical issue if i go away
i'll come back i'll find another
computer in fact if someone's listening
to this
right now who is within uh walking
distance of where i am
maybe having a standby computer that's
all powered up would probably be a good
thing but i'm going to assume that
somehow
these machines are built with an
equilibrium that they can
build back up or at least stay static
without
going down further okay so other
questions and again we're going to bring
barry barrish in about 3
30 but keep your keep your questions
coming
um what do we have here uh osger
asks why is there something rather than
nothing
i don't know the answer to that question
obviously that's the deepest
of all questions in some sense deepest
of all physics
questions you know why is there a
universe at
all leibniz famously asked a version of
that question
and we've been struggling to gain
insight into it ever since it's not as
though many physicists
spend their time in their office
thinking about why is there something
rather than nothing rather
we assume that there's some answer to
that question god
physics we don't know quantum mechanics
and then we look at the something
and we try to make sense of the
something by developing
math and equations observation
experiment to make sense of planets and
stars and people
and black holes and galaxies and so on
there are
ideas however speculative though they
may be
about why there is something rather than
nothing and quantum mechanics may be
key to that you may be familiar in
quantum mechanics you can have
energy eruptions in space where
momentarily energy is extracted
from the vacuum say in the form of a
electron positron
pair they then collide give that energy
back to empty space but there is this
kind of
eruption of something out of nothing
there's still empty space
already so it's not pure nothingness but
you can imagine a version of that story
that might involve our
universe emerging from a
quantum fluctuation a quantum eruption
and maybe there's a negative version of
our universe and maybe somehow
our universe and that anti-version don't
find each other they don't
quickly collide with one another giving
the energy back
so maybe there's kind of a mirror
version of our universe balancing us
all out and we still therefore in total
have
nothing zero in total but zero has
been rewritten as our positive universe
and some other negative universe
and that may
one day shed light and why there's
something rather than nothing but my
first answer
is the most honest accurate answer that
anybody can give today which is
why is there something rather than
nothing from the standpoint of
fundamental physics answer
we do not know okay
back to some questions over here oh good
i'm at five percent
power all right i'm a little less
concerned the vector is heading in the
right direction
um tar says physicist sean carroll a
friend of mine
has been complaining about how the
physics community is avoiding to indulge
in understanding the true nature of
quantum mechanics
and are just happy with the results your
views
i i share sean's perspective
on that i too am among
i think a minority of physicists and i
can't tell you
the percentages right haven't done any
polling
but just through my informal
conversations with colleagues
most are less than thrilled
to engage with some of the
fundamental mysteries of quantum
mechanics and are more happy
to use quantum mechanics to just figure
things
out what are the mysteries that i'm
referring to the mystery of the quantum
measurement problem
how does the world transition from the
fuzzy nebulous haze
of a probability profile that comes out
of the wave function of quantum
mechanics how do you transition
from that probabilistic haze of many
possibilities to the definite reality
that we encounter
upon observation or measurement of the
world nobody knows
the answer to that and that's a pretty
fundamental question
other fundamental questions is the wave
function is the probability wave
real is it as real as say
an electromagnetic wave a gravitational
wave as we'll be talking about
or is that probability wave is that wave
function simply
a mathematical articulation of the best
understanding we have of a physical
system but the wave is not
really out there undulating in the world
if that wave is real and you're doing
say
standard non-relativistic quantum
accounts that you study say
in high school or college for some of
you if you're looking at an
n body system in three dimensions
then that wave function has three n plus
one arguments
three n plus one arguments which means
even the picture
of a wave undulating through three
dimensions of space is just a wrong
picture
for the non-relativistic wave function
the wave function
is undulating through a 3m plus one
or if you take the time out just make
that a movie of its
shape over time undulating through a 3n
dimensional spatial environment
is there any reality to those three n
dimensions
configuration space or not so these are
the kinds of questions
that people who worry about the
foundations that quantum mechanics do
think about
i will say this i wrote a book
called fabric of the cosmos back in oh
man 20 20 2004
i think young man back then got a long
time ago 16 years ago
ah insane that's a whole nother story
but but here's the way i reason i bring
that up in that book
i took on issues of quantum entanglement
and and
and epr and that sort of stuff and i do
remember
colleagues at the time saying yeah it's
kind of interesting to talk about that
but
like why like why would you spend any
time
thinking about epr and entanglement and
so forth
and short time later as theoretical
physicists began to
grapple more fully with black holes and
how black holes interface with quantum
mechanics
these issues of entanglement and epr
became central to the kinds of work that
we need to do to make progress
at the frontier so certainly that aspect
of quantum mechanics
has taken hold in the majority
of the physics community i would no
longer say that that is a backwater
and in the 80s or 90s it was definitely
a backwater people weren't focused upon
entanglement and einstein podolski rose
and that has largely changed
so the other qualities of quantum
mechanics that are still mysterious i
imagine
there will come a time when people spend
more time thinking about them
as well all right a couple more
questions before we
transition over to today's
guest conversation um let me see if
something catches my
eye over here um
uh pre-tom asked sir can mars be made
habitable
in our lifetime it depends what you mean
by habitable can we make
regions of the planet conducive to our
form of life
by building structures that allow us to
survive within them yeah
they're they're on the table in fact you
can search online there's some
clever ideas that have been developed
and no doubt that some of these
can work in our lifetime if you're
talking about terraforming mars
and turning mars into the new garden of
eden
that i don't anticipate happening in
our lifetime okay
let's do uh at least have a couple
minutes i'd like to start at 3
30 with our next phase of our
conversation here let me just uh all
right what do we have uh um
serena shao is it possible for a human
to live near a black hole
perhaps in a type 2 civilization you
know it's funny the type 1 type 2
civilizations i never really
got into that categorization
scheme it has to do with i guess the
amount of the kinds of energy sources
that that civilization has conquered
so maybe what is type 2 has has
conquered
solar system level or galactic somebody
can tell me i don't have that
category categorization why am i having
trouble with that word
uh in mind but uh can
a person live near a black hole yeah
in fact we may we could be living near
one right now in the sense that if
there's a huge black hole
then it's event horizon is far away from
its center if you recall
and i mentioned schwarzschild solution
and sometimes
we talk a little math here what is the
radius
of a black hole of mass m by radius i
mean what is the value of the short
style parameter
r and the answer is 2 g m over c
squared twice newton's constant times
the mass divided by the speed
of light squared and so if you have an
ever greater mass black hole r which is
linearly proportional to m will just get
bigger and bigger
it also turns out that the curvature
near the edge the event horizon of the
black hole
gets smaller and smaller the bigger the
black hole gets
so the forces that you'd feel near the
edge of a black hole
in some sense become ever smaller
as that black hole gets ever bigger and
so if you have a big enough black hole
you might be hovering right near the
edge and not
even know it in fact we could have all
just crossed over the edge
of a black hole we wouldn't necessarily
know it either if that black hole was
sufficiently
large so yeah yeah in principle now as
the black hole gets smaller and smaller
it's more of a challenge the
acceleration that you have to
constantly apply to stay outside that
black hole becomes ever more intense but
there's nothing in principle that says
that you can't
live outside the edge of a black hole
and of course if you're far away from
the edge
then we're all living outside the edge
of a black hole
all right um uh
sam asks a professor green how are
particle
pairs still entangled when
one member of the pair is sucked into a
black hole
how can they still be communicating well
yeah sam good
that is the kind of question
that people have been struggling with a
lot in
recent years because you're right if you
if you have a pair of entangled
particles you know spinning up and
spinning down is the canonical example
that we often use
if you have this pair of particles that
are entangled in this way
you separate them we've discussed in
previous gatherings how there can be a
kind of quantum thread
that stitches these two particles
together making them
act as one even though they're widely
separated such that for instance if you
measure one of these particles
you find it up the distant particle
immediately snaps
out of that fuzzy quantum haze and
points down
instantaneously even though you didn't
do anything to it so that's traditional
entanglement
what happens to entanglement in the
vicinity of a black hole and in
particular
if one member of the entangled pair
falls in and the other rushes away
how does that affect the entanglement
now according to
the most straightforward vanilla
interpretation of schwarzschild's
solution to the einstein field equations
the entanglement should persist why the
edge of a black hole
as i've emphasized is not a place in
space
where anything happens there's no
signpost
that says you are now at the edge of the
black hole
it is an ordinary location in space
which has the
unusual feature that you then can't
turn around and exit the region to which
you entered
but you don't feel anything it's not
like the bars go down and you're
locked in so because nothing happens at
the edge of a black hole
nothing singular happens at the event
horizon of a black hole the belief was
the entanglement just persists period
now for reasons that would take me a
little far afield to describe
more recently as people have thought
that through further
and wondered about the radiation the
hawking radiation that comes out of a
black hole
and the entanglement that that yields
and the kind of entanglement that that
radiation must be subject to to carry
away the information within a black hole
when these considerations are thought
through carefully
some have concluded that the particle
inside the black hole and outside the
black called the entanglement
is destroyed the entanglement is lost
and if that's the case it's as if the
event horizon kind of snaps
the thread of quantum entanglement
uniting the two particles one inside one
outside
and when you snap that thread of quantum
entanglement
it generates energy now imagine
many particles all over the edge of a
black hole some inside some outside all
entangled
if all of their lines of entanglement
are snapped there's a lot of energy
along the event horizon of the black
hole so much energy
that the temperature is huge and the
conditions are extreme
and that is what has given rise to the
name firewall
for the event horizon of the black
holder proposal not universally agreed
upon
that the edge of a black hole might
actually be a real
location in space there is a sign post
there
the signpost is a firewall of intense
heat
that when you go toward the edge of the
black hole you are incinerated
so the snapping of the lines of quantum
entanglement that sam asks about
may be the origin of a new way of
thinking about black holes
where the edge of a black hole is a fire
wall
okay good question with that let's
the warm-up act if you will let's turn
to the uh
the main event which i am looking
forward to enormously
which is a conversation that i'll now
have with
barry bears let me give a little
introduction before bringing him in
barry won
the nobel prize in 2017 for his work
on ligo laser interferometer
gravitational wave observatory will talk
some
about that he was a principal
investigator
for ligo 1994 its director from 1997 to
2005.
and he is credited with
making substantial contributions
to this incredible
scientific achievement of detecting the
first
ever gravitational wave rippling through
the fabric of space so with that let me
bring barry into
our discussion here barry how are you
doing good how are you
great to see you yeah good to see you
too i can't was the last time i saw you
was it
at the world science festival in new
york or was it in tenerife i can't
remember which happened
i think i think tenerife was after
tenerife was after yeah okay great yeah
so i remember that was a fun meeting out
there yeah it was beautiful
a beautiful environment now we can only
dream of being in places like that so uh
where are you now you're somewhere in
california brazilian santa we live in
santa monica and i'm getting money
a hundred meters from the beach here oh
that's nice yeah good
maybe 80 some degrees today so it's nice
yeah it's a little warm here too usually
it's freezing up here in upstate
new york but we're having a momentary uh
state of warm weather which is kind of
nice um
so you know i i just would love to talk
about
obviously the detection of gravitational
waves and what's happening now
to bring people up speed and what's
happening but before we do that
if you don't mind just a little bit of a
background
on you our audience loves to learn about
the journey that these great scientists
such as yourself have been on
and you know last last week we spoke
with another
nobel laureate harold varmus i don't
know if you know harold yeah i do
all you know about lori you probably all
know each other right well
not only that we may be like second
cousins bearish as a family name
about it in his family we're not sure
how to connect it but that's interesting
i think the reason i bring him up i
didn't know that connection but the
reason i bring it up is
you know harold began interested in in
literature
and in reading and in writing and only
much later on
transitioned into science and
i think i read or heard that that you
also had a
yeah an interest of a similar sword so
so
so you weren't like a a math chemistry
physics
kid you know five years old yeah no i
first i came from a family where neither
parents went to college so i didn't have
much
and we also didn't have much money so
i i just was a public school kid um
with very little guidance anywhere are
you still there
yep sure i am yeah i see it just chose
me yeah
anyway uh but when i was a kid i like to
read a lot
and i grew up i'm here in southern
california not so far from hollywood
and uh of course in hollywood
storytelling's a big deal
yeah and so i i like to to read and i
like storytelling
and so i was attracted to the to words
more than science
although as a kid i was good at it and
want some math contests and stuff but
it really wasn't my interest and i i
discovered and then i was the editor of
the school newspapers i like to write
and read and all this and then
i so i thought uh when i was about 13 or
so i discovered
good literature and you know read the
russian novels and things like that
and uh i thought i'd be a novelist
that's that was my goal at
14 or 15. and that got cured
by a high school english teacher my
first
real class in literature and
she assigned a book you can maybe guess
at the book as i introduce it
which managed to cure me from literature
and it was the wrong book to give to
this 15 year old i don't know about
another one
but to me and uh i read this book and
decided i should do something else with
my life i wasn't
going to tell us are you going to tell
us what to do i'm going to tell you how
i was just giving you a minute to yeah
so anyway the the book was moby dick ah
now i don't know if you've read bumpy
dick wait you were 15 you said
yeah so i was given moby dick as a
seventh grader which
is even younger well you maybe you're
you're more sophisticated than me
i had trouble i had absolutely no sense
of what a metaphor was okay
yeah moby dick is one big metaphor
that's all it is
and so i read this book and there was a
big chapter on the great white whale
which is very important once you
understand the book but to me it was
like the most
boring thing i could possibly imagine
because the whole thing was over my head
so anyway so because you know later i
read i read it
later uh you know sometime after college
and i enjoyed it a lot it's great
literature so
it was me it was the wrong book for a 15
year old yeah
it was for you too at 14 or 15.
but it would have killed a writer too
probably
and so uh basically that made me wander
in another direction
and i decided to become that i had to
figure out how to make a living and
stuff so i was going to become
an engineering student right and
i was almost the last class i don't know
why they had them in los angeles public
schools that had a winter graduating
class
which is unusual but and i was
uh i my horizon didn't go as far as the
east coast i just kind of saw so caltech
was one of my
interests also stanford but they only
took classes in september
so i applied for the engineering school
at ucla in berkeley
and and i went to berkeley i was an
engineering student for
one semester but i took freshman physics
and at that time in berkeley they were
discovering all the elementary particles
up at the radiation lab
and i got and owen chamberlain who
discovered the anti-proton was my
advisor once i switched to physics and
it was just the
you know the romance of discovery and
yeah and so forth they got me started in
physics i changed to physics and then
the rest so so do you have a
half-written novel
sitting in a shoebox
i the other thing i always thought that
you know
physicists don't can't do physics
forever although i keep trying
and uh so i was gonna come back to
trying to write when i got
older but i keep uh yeah i keep doing
physics
instead well you know it's good to write
you're doing physics
yeah so so so but so you were
in first uh one of the leaders of the
superconducting super collider right
back in the 90s
which i i think most people who are
watching this know what that was you
know this big
powerful accelerator that was going to
be built down in texas
how disappointing was it when that was
shuttered
and how surprising was it to you that
after the amount of work that had been
done
in fact you can tell us how far had had
things gone that it was
funding well altogether uh about
15 or 20 of 10 billion dollars had been
spent
so they had dug a lot of underground uh
tunneling and a certain amount of a
campus that was going to be there so
that's a significant
i was on the experimental side the uh
a uh uh
a physicist i i was a co-director of one
of the two
project uh physics experiments that was
going to be
there done there i was completely
determined to to detect the higgs boson
as the first thing and so we tried hard
to make a detector that had the ability
to see the higgs 2 gamma which was the
the process that we thought was the most
likely yep at time
and that required certain amount of
technology development which is ended up
in the lhc experiments
to make a thin enough uh
volume where you can actually detect the
gamma rays because uh
otherwise you get them all mixed up with
the charged particles yep
and and so were you surprised in
whatever year
i was a little bit so i wasn't i wasn't
an employee of the
ssc itself but i had actually recruited
a lot of
scientists to work with us that got
employed by the
ssc i would say caltech still and iu is
just commuting back and forth to texas
yeah i didn't think it would actually
get
closed down but it was threatened to be
closed down it was a new congress
and uh uh i wish i could say i had the
insight and so forth but i didn't you
know
in october of 93 that it uh
got closed and we weren't prepared for
it i mean there was a lot of talk about
yeah
now i know there were hearings and i i
believe stephen weinberg
spoke at a hearing and others as well in
the end
do you think that physicists could have
was it our fault as a community for not
getting enough excitement public
excitement behind these ideas back then
was that or was it
destined to be shuttered no matter what
well i think
um yeah i don't think it was the cost i
think it's more what you say because
what the this was a new conservative
congress
and they were determined to demonstrate
they were turning off something
and it was either the space station or
this of course the space station
was more expensive it ends up being much
much more but
that time it was well known it was more
expensive so it wasn't
because of that the nasa had more
uh connections with industry and
powerful people that helped
but i think we failed to make the
the story that fundamental science
needed to be supported
and all the right reasons so i think it
uh
yeah now surely thereafter i guess i
mean what was the time interval that you
you were able to
shift over yeah so i had uh
caltech is a zero growth institution you
know we're the same size as when i came
right it was my first job and so we have
this
feature that you know when you have a
physics department
or any department and you want to stay
at the forefront how do you
evolve it when everybody wants to
replace themselves when they
retire and start leave and it's very
hard to kind of evolve
with the science and caltech i don't
know i can't say there's a magic formula
but there's a lot of effort in trying to
make every single faculty appointment
the best faculty appointment you can
make independent of kind of specialty
because of this
zero growth because of that i was
uh involved i started this same year on
the faculty as kip thorn and we were
good friends
yeah and uh i suppose he had convinced
me that
it was a time for us to get an
experimental effort not for me
but in uh at caltech in
gravitational waves
we failed at the beginning but then we
got a uh experiment got approval
the next appointment when somebody left
was uh was in
gravit would be in gravitational waves
and maybe two appointments
that started it and then uh because
the project was big for a little place
like caltech
i then served on a oversight group
that tried to handle the fact that how
is caltech going to handle such a big
expensive
uh as this and uh
so and also i uh
was very sympathetic with the the goals
i thought
originally i hated the i didn't think
things could be
done because the original idea was to
use a big
bar that was used
and i always thought that was a bad idea
uh as an experimentalist because
if you have a big bar of aluminum or
whatever it is you hit it with a hammer
and it rings at a particular frequency
and that's where it's sensitive you get
that frequency but
who says that the gravitational waves
you're going to find are going to be
you know at that frequency yeah that's
what i was trying to do i guess
yeah and that's what joe weber was
trying to do right right
yeah no there's a good picture of him
yeah apparently i'm just wondering so
when you
when you begin to think about switching
over did you have to like quickly
run to meisner thorne and wheeler or
like did you have did you already have
knowledge i did i took i took general
relativity as a
student i was always interested in this
problem yeah
and so uh but when it changed so i i
i knew about it what i didn't know was
how realistic
and i don't think anybody really knew
very well but compare coming out of
particle physics where you can predict
pretty well uh the fact that uh
whether you could predict the sources
and rates and so forth
was pretty fuzzy i must say the only
observations
were a few binary neutron stars in our
own galaxy
right uh no black hole there's no there
so
so it was really a stretch to think that
you're going to spend
years building something and know what
the sensitivity targets were
so we zeroed in on the only one we could
predict at all which was the
binary neutron star system and uh
and that ended up being uh what our goal
was
it turned out that the black hole
binaries were a little bit
more prolific than that in terms of our
ability our
we didn't have to have quite the
sensitivity right
so so when you started in on this uh
like i can understand like finding the
higgs the mindset
of the community was the higgs exists
right
we just got to find it right it's the
final particle of the standard model it
all works it's got to be there but with
gravitational waves there was a sense in
the community
that sure they're they're they're real
but there are many who felt we will
never be able to detect them
so this is a different mindset as a as
opposed to just a shift of field right
well in terms of what you said whether
they'd exist i think by the time
certainly i got involved people thought
they were einstein had trouble whether
he's
in trouble yeah yeah for a long time and
it was yeah he wrote papers back in 16
18 19 16 19 18 which were
uh he wrote a paper the 1930s
when he returned to the refuge yes
exactly where his original title was
do gravitational waves exist yeah
and that's you know 20 years after 15
years after he had predicted that was a
kind of strange
paper right but the problem was when he
submitted that
paper uh in general relativity as you
well know it's easy to get these
uh coordinate singularities yep to
really set up the problem right to
avoid those and so he yeah he worried
that what he was getting was
technical and not real and
that got straightened out for that paper
he renamed it and
he had a war with physical review
because he
didn't want it refereed it's a story but
uh now but then
the i think in the most people
for the community think it was a meeting
in chapel hill north carolina
after einstein died in 1958
where uh the community finally believed
this is the gr community general
relativity community not the broader
physics building
they really existed there was a a nice
derivation from first principles
and uh feinman feynman was at that
meeting
and uh i don't know you've probably
heard of the sticky bead argument
yeah yeah so that's where he made that
argument the stickybeat argument which
is
basically the argument that if gra in
his mind that if gravitational waves
exist they have to be able to transfer
energy
and this was his picture at least in the
kadunkan way that they could transfer
energy
and was also i think the stimulus for
the bar because
uh the sticky bead was on a was a rod
with
rings on it much like the bar so right
right
after that meeting so it didn't take us
a hundred years as experimentals it took
us half that because the theorists
screwed around for 50 years and then
and then the problem became an
experimental one
and uh and i liked the problem from the
beginning i thought it was the kind of
thing
that i would like to do so i like to but
as i said i didn't like the idea the
bars
to me seemed like a bad approach i
didn't have an alternate myself
but then when so when was the alternate
when was the
interferometer idea first the first the
first
record of it was actually not
surprisingly
in jtp the russian uh
journal which had a little short article
no
detail calculations in the in the
early 60s for interferometry and
later in the 60s actually weber a
student of weber
built a first interferometer a test
interferometer in his lab
it was kind of empirical and almost the
same period
ray weiss my colleague was teaching
general relativity at mit
and kind of made an exercise for the
students
to to see what kind of detector would be
needed and that's turned out to be kind
of a
unpublished classical first
write down but i i was familiar with
that that
turned many of us toward interferometry
and we talked about starting a group at
caltech it was to work on interferometry
not bars bars were getting better and
better because
experimentalists are clever and they
kept making them colder
and so if you make it cold it's quieter
we're trying to do that now with the
with the interferometers
when was the first version of ligo built
that was well the
there were test interferometers never
never with the idea that you could
measure uh gravitational waves but learn
how to do the interferometry
right interferometry if i could pick a
number
you know we all saw an interferometer
sometime
in a freshman lab or somewhere and you
see these fringes
and maybe you could differentiate them
to a partner 100 or pardon 50 or
something
and the good
interferometers that people have
technically maybe apart
a thousand or a part in ten thousand we
had to do a part in
10 to the 12th when you put the numbers
in
right that required a really a lot of
advancements in how to do interferometry
itself
have enough photons but have enough uh
optical
advances that you could do
interferometry at the level of one part
and 10 to the 12th the wavelength of the
light
right but at some point you felt that
you understood it well enough that there
was a chance that this could work yeah
yeah so if you took the time at the time
i got in but i
had i was helping oversee it at celtic
before that
the time i got in um
we were within with uh with the tests
that have been done on test
interferometers
this factor of 10 to the 12th was aimed
at doing the neutron star binary where
we had some numbers
and we were within a factor of 100 of
that and there was nothing technically
that limited us
so it looked pop possible with more
developments
right uh that you could do it at that
point so i i thought it was an
experimental
and today even what limits us is
technical problems not
science uh right in in terms of
shielding and and things like that in
terms of the future
so if you ask what the what's the future
of this thing if you talk about making
um doing better than say
better than the higgs at cern you're
limited by physics the problem is that
higgs is this little bump on top of
physics
so you have to know the physics he can
only know it so well so you can
so if you want to see if the higgs has a
partner there's a problem that
you're limited you can't see it if it's
below the
uh the background signals for example
here we don't have that the background
is
is physical background it's not physics
and so what limits us now just doesn't
have anything to do with
with science so even though we can only
detect
you know distances down to 10 to the
minus 22 centimeters which is pretty
small
yeah you can do better and i i can say
easily you could do better if you could
cool the whole apparatus immediately
or that you change the optics and put a
more powerful laser in or
you know different different things you
have to learn how to do those things but
they're technical
so if you look at the future for
gravitational waves
it's going to really evolve first
ourselves over the next few years but
it it's not limited it's limited in the
sense that we have these big detectors
maybe somebody will learn how to do an
atomic interferometry or something where
we can make it smaller
yeah so they're big and expensive but
they're not limited by nature they're
limited by
us basically so just to give a little
more background to folks who may not be
as familiar as some others
listening to this so when a
gravitational wave rolls by
what mathematics say the signature
should be i think you even have a visual
of this if i'm not mistaken
uh let me see i i i just make it
three maybe slide yes like slide two or
so
start with slide two because it shows
ligo yeah if you can bring that up
that'd be great
yeah so slide two i guess is a is a shot
of uh
just it's like itself slight
side two is like off then is it yeah
so just for for reference if people have
seen this but
logo those though it's shaped like an l
those two arms are four kilometers on
the side
that means the fundamental 10 to the
minus 21 that i talk about come becomes
10 to the minus 18
the size of that you have to do so by
making it big
we can have to measure uh interferometry
at the level of the size of the proton
one thousandth of that the two detectors
are identical
very different physical locations the
one on the right
is in a swamp and forests and
pine forests in louisiana and the other
one is on the doe reservation hanford
washington
and they perform the same as i'll show
you in the first sig in the signature
and those are just interferometers that
work like if we can change the next
slide
slide the three
okay so this is the idea basically that
uh you want to measure this
uh small number of meters 10 to the
minus 21
and in order to do that there's two
problems that you have to solve and then
you can do it
uh first the idea of interferometry you
start with the laser beam on the left
hits a mirror in the center and you make
two arms that are the same length you
split the beam so half of it goes
to the up and half of it to the right if
everything's right
when they come back if you invert one
compared to the other they'll cancel
and your little photo detector sees
nothing
but if they move a little bit one of
them moves a little bit relative to the
other one
then they come back out of phase and you
see a signal you see some light and
that's the signal
to do that as i mentioned the accuracy
is the bottom
in the bottom little insert that you
have to do is
10 to the minus 12 times the wavelength
of the light you're doing
that's the technical challenge and
that's really hard
the second problem is that the earth
we're here on the earth we do it on the
earth we do it where earth is the
quietest which is
basically we've learned by evolution
that's where our ears work and we can
communicate with each other
so we work from 10 to 10 000 hertz like
audioband
even though it has nothing to do with
audio right but
the earth still even in that frequency
band shakes
much too much for us and so we have to
knock that down by also a factor of
amazingly a factor of 10 to the 12th but
it's just a technical problem
we do it by and we did it and it wasn't
good enough that's one of the reasons it
took us so long
we do it by just a very fancy version of
what's in your car
that is shock absorbers shock absorbers
absorb the
bump that you go over in your car and
then transfer it to lower energy
and it feels smooth and here we do the
same
your shakes we move it down to lower
frequency
uh with just very fancy shock absorbers
and we had four
layers of it these are like suspending
the
mirror from these pendula that uh each
absorbs some of the shake relative to
the next and so on yeah
i think if we go two slides forward to
slide five
you can see a picture of it kind of a
schematic of it
and then you'll see the the if you need
the elevator speech for how we
experimentally
did this it's on that slide basically so
here's a picture of us making sure we're
isolated from the earth
so it's a big vacuum tank connected to
the interferometry and inside of it is
this thing on the bottom is the mirror
and it hangs on a pendulum
yep the first thing to realize is if i
have a pendulum
and i hang it you just hang something
and you move the top it doesn't move the
bottom very much
we all have seen that so horizontal
motions
are taken care of pretty well in a
pendulum and then the vertical ones more
uh you know in layers of shock absorbers
which are just kind of shown
over on the left which is built into the
vacuum system so a combination of this
pendulum and the shock absorbers and
that
in effect got us to an isolation
which was pretty good but not good
enough of 10 to the 12th
and we achieved that 10 years before we
detected gravitational waves
that wasn't good enough and so what we
had to do finally
is to steal another silly idea i mean
shock absorbers are well known we just
did it a little better
the second idea is what you do when you
get onto an airplane
and you don't like the engine noise you
get one of these earphones the bose
earphones you put them in your ears
and the engine roar goes away pretty
well noise cancellation
yeah yeah yeah active ca and but the
stewardess comes up to you and you still
hear her when she asks you whether you
want coffee or a drink or something
and so the the the consistent motion in
the back that comes from the engines you
just cancel when it's detected and so
the idea was the same here that you have
to add
active isolation that actually
has what we had did is build into this
thing
uh seismometers it's a little harder
than the airplane
one because we have to tell the
direction so the residual motion that's
still there
we have to tell the direction and we
just push back against it and cancel it
right and that gave us the extra factor
of 100
and enabled the detection of
gravitational waves
and again and the other reason the fact
you have two of these machines one in
louisiana and washington yeah
that if there's any kind of you know
crazy shaking that somehow influences
the machine
influence not the other you'll be able
to at least know that that's right
any the the gravitational wave has to be
in the two within the speed of light
right and anything else more or less is
the speed of sound or something else
there won't be
the speed of light in the sense of the
speed of light travel time between the
two
machines yeah right right exactly so
so you made these amazing technological
advances you build the machine
um for a while you don't hear anything
in the first version
of like you do the upgrade then
the upgrade upgrade included a more
powerful laser and other things
but the key one was this seismic
so then the day happened september
of 2015
so there's this unexpected signal where
the two
machines twitch they shake in a manner
that
look pretty much the same the time delay
between them as you say
is the light travel time between them
all looking good
but you were presumably not ready to
celebrate when you saw
that it was like too unexpected in a way
right i mean it was it was it was even
more than that it was too unexpected and
too
perfect the uh
the uh we were and we had just turned on
so it was a brand new fixed-up detector
that had
active seismic fancier laser all kinds
of other things
and we turn it on and we were in
what we call an engineering run which
just indicates that we weren't
really settled down yet and that's when
this event came
different people had different reactions
we're human beings so there's some
people and they were right
that immediately were ready to celebrate
and others
like myself for me it was a kind of a
nightmare
yep you went out with this and it turned
out that it was a prank a hoax a mistake
yeah so there were there were two
possibilities there were two
possibilities really
uh and we had to trace down both one was
you know we're on the internet and so
forth is there any way that somebody
just inserts inserted this in our data
stream somehow the data comes from the
two labs to caltech and then goes out in
the world
it was first observed by a postdoc of
ours in in germany
so uh so and that's a hard thing to
trace because you have to know how
clever people might have been
to somehow get it there we had to trace
the signals all the way back to their
origin to do that and that took about a
month
and of hard work and uh the other
problem is maybe
we had done a lot to upgrade the
apparatus maybe the apparatus
can hiccup in some way that it gives you
something that you think is a
gravitational wave and so to
do that we have to run and test the
apparatus over some period of time
to see that it doesn't generate those
and you could have imagined
a coincident hiccup i mean something
that would have what we do
yeah what we do to check that they
couldn't happen is put them
out of time with each other and see how
many times
they would by statistics land on top of
each other
and that took about a month of just
taking data and then
and then we were convinced but as you
know you didn't know about it yet
i think i heard rumblings rumblings but
but uh and so then we
and people always ask how did this big
collaboration keep so quiet the next
piece was pretty easy and that is
the idea that we should telling
everybody in the collaboration the idea
that we should figure out what it is
first
not just give it out and let other
people figure out what it is
i see and uh you know that's as a
scientist you want to do that you want
some time to know what you saw before
somebody else does
and that took another month or so so
that got us into november
and uh and then we decided we're going
to
publish it and uh you know
i had been president of the aps at one
point so i was insistent we published an
american uh not in nature or science
and not in nature and so we went to
fizzrev letters and they had a
policy that you could on exception make
longer than a three and a half page
article
so we called them and asked to make a
ten page article the reason we wanted 10
pages
is that we knew not only did we have to
make the case to the
critics our own colleagues that are
critics but
this would have enough general interest
that we had to write this
initial article so that you didn't have
to be an expert in gravitational waves
to read the article
that made it uh pretty challenging
right we told the fizzrev letters
that we would they agreed and that we
would give it to them by i think it was
november 30th
or december 1st we got together
to make the final decision we wrote it
in that time scale we got together to
make the final decision
and then there was haggling the haggling
was
over adjectives basically is it do you
declare a discovery
an observation uh you know
it's not a word so it's adjectives
basically and so it took us a
another four or five days to decide to
determine that
and uh we then contacted fizzrevletters
and
and said okay it's ready and they said
whoops we can't do it now because it's
too close to christmas
this is doing this very fast and secure
referee so we said okay then we won't
give it to you
to you until the first of the year the
reason i tell that part of the story
is that on december 26th we saw our
second event
and i just have to say personally
despite
all the fall and me thinking that at
every level i was convinced
seeing the second event i had a sigh of
relief there's something about
corroborating your result that it looks
very different than the first one
but as much as we convinced ourselves
with all the tests
seeing a second event which we didn't
announce to the
public for months afterwards we only
announced the first one but we knew
that we had the second one at that point
and at least for me personally that was
a
the clincher so take us through the work
that took you through november as you
described it in terms of figuring out
the source uh how do you how do you so
you have this
twitch i don't even know if we have the
uh the wave form
waveform maybe i did the waveform let me
see
we may have somewhere well there we go
we have the waveform
oh there it is okay so so this is the
amazingly this is essentially raw data
you know everything you see when you see
journals
people have analyzed it doesn't look
anything like what you see online
this only has a filter to throw away
very high and low frequencies outside of
our band that's all that's done to it
otherwise
it's just the data itself so that
helps you a lot in understanding things
on the left
are the two detectors in the top and the
center
band and they look alike to the eye and
the bottom one is just putting one on
top of the other
and sliding it by 6.7
milliseconds which is the within the 10
millisecond
speed of light difference between the
two sites and they look
to the eye on the same as each other but
it shows better on the right
so on the right hand to see what it is
the top two are the same two traces that
are shown on the left
the second line where there's some more
the smooth lines through it
are the calculations from general
relativity
uh for and we did it for different cases
for the case of
of the parameters which i don't give
here of two
nearly 30 solar mass black holes
colliding
and you can see they look except being
smoother because it's a calculation
they look the same the trivial way to
just see if they are the same
and see if anything shows is to subtract
one from the other
and that's done in the third frame and
you can see just noise
and that's just the fact that our
measurements have noise on them
but there's no pattern or anything that
shows so even without fitting
it gives you a pretty good picture that
you know the data
looks just like einstein's equations
predict so here's my question barry
which uh i know we've discussed
on occasion now and then but i wouldn't
mind bringing up again here so to do
that if you could leave that graph back
up
if you would to do that middle
calculation
the general relativity calculation
requires
sophisticated numerical understanding of
absolute injuries and and you guys
knew that you'd need that in order to
match up the observation
with the theory yeah but that that's a
relatively recent breakthrough in the
time scales that we're talking about so
you were building ligo
yeah absolutely without having the
ability
while you were building it to have done
the analysis to figure out
if you got a signal what was the source
of this signal it would
make you nervous for for years on end
before
yeah well one of one of the things that
made me nervous but
yes it made me nervous and the history
of that was we we recognized that
uh to the first part of the waveform you
can do with just
general relativity and uh post-newtonian
calculations
but when it gets to where the real
energy is at the near the
merger itself you need to use numerical
relativity which
is something that you can't do the
calculations by hand it's too much work
and so you have to do it by computer and
this was the challenge that challenge
was taken up in the 90s
at the nsf they started they they
initiated a
program called the grand challenge which
failed
uh basically numerical relativists uh
you know better than ice those were
individuals around different
universities and
there wasn't kind of the effort to do
that or the technique and
and uh then we when that ended
at uh at caltech we had a visit we had
some money for a visitor program
as we were building ligo and we brought
people that were numerical relativists
to
work for a while we also didn't solve
the problem then it was finally solved
as you said in uh
well before we made the detection but
206 207 something like that
and then it had to be applied so we
didn't have real waveforms
that were calculated and applied until
not
very long before we made the detection
so some
by some miracle these things came
together at the same time
so it's wonderful that it did in fact
the fact that it was the year 2015
100 years later a celebration of
einstein's
own discovery of the equations of the
general theory relativity just adds a
certain kind of poetry to it all
yeah it makes people who are scientists
like you and i kind of wonder about
things these coincidences that happen
yeah yeah exactly so that so that
is the the first detection of
gravitational waves
these two roughly as you say 30 solar
mass black holes orbiting each other 1.3
billion light years away colliding
giving off this
tidal wave in space that we're able to
ultimately detect with the machine that
you built
good so so rightfully you guys win the
nobel prize for this
incredibly exciting you could stop at
that point
but of course it's too exciting to keep
on going so you can give us a sense of
what happened since i mean you mentioned
the second detection how many detections
do you have in terms of i'm going to
show you so so let me say a few words
and then uh
so uh interestingly
uh you know the discovery itself is
important it's a
long thing and now we can do one whole
branch
of important work and that is is
how much is einstein's theory of general
relativity the right theory of general
relativity
there are alternates around and how well
can we test that
and uh so one branch of what we've been
doing
since then is to try to test general
relativity we've seen no violations
the simplest test we do is that you can
relate to
is to add a uh
like in electromagnetism we have the
photon add a graviton
and figure out if it had any mass at all
what it would do to the signal and if it
had any mass at all it would
add dispersion to the signal and we can
calculate that
and so we basically have put a quite
small limit
on the mass of a of a graviton that's
not the best test
of course the best tests are to take the
parameters of general relativity
and compare not just how well they fit
einstein's equations which we've done so
far with our accuracy
but there are alternate theories and the
trouble rate we have right now compared
to say
particle physics as i know it is the
alternate theories don't
typically aren't developed enough to
give us
measurements that we can compare so we
can say
yes it fits einsteins but it also fits
something else because
that's something else so right now we're
in this i think not ideal mode where
we're looking for violations in
einstein's equation
rather than compare differences between
uh
different theories because they're just
not mature enough but like if you look
at a brand's dickey type theory
adding a scalar field is that the kind
of thing that you yeah
yeah so you add that but we don't have
predictions
calculated at the level that we can
actually compare it in detail with our
waveforms
got it so you know the question is if we
want to have a
an alternative that you want to
seriously look at you have to do the
work
to actually compare it we haven't done
that yet the other branch
is which is you know easier to relate to
for everybody except the hardcore
physicists who want to look at
this that is uh that this
represents a different way of looking at
the sky yeah we now have the ability to
look at
gravity gravitational waves from the sky
and not just electromagnetic radiation
and that we've always thought is the
real
real long-term benefit of this whole
thing is that it opens up the
possibility of
really expanding uh uh
observational astronomy into a broader
broader realm and and we saw that in the
first case
when we so the black holes they're not
seen
they shouldn't be seen and they haven't
been seen but then we saw our first case
of what we originally thought was the
first
source we'd see and that was binary
neutron star mergers
and and in that case
we actually that actually was seen
by many telescopes around the world we
saw it
at the same time within 1.7
microseconds the same time as 1.7
seconds the same time as
uh was seen by a high-energy gamma-ray
observatory
and uh then that gave us enough
confidence to
inform the the observation
astronomers from around the world they
have a way to do that
and roughly half of the astronomical
instruments in the world pointed at this
and measured it and saw it and measured
it in all the different wavelengths
half half of them in the world they have
that level of half of the
half of the kind of amateur stuff but
something like there's
there's something like 2 000
identifiable uh you know telescopes of
some sort or another you can identify
and roughly half of them
right because of course with the initial
black hole detection
you didn't even have enough data to
pinpoint where on the sky
and honestly we couldn't do it here
either
with two detectors we needed
triangulation
yeah right the third one we got was uh
in
it was the one we were competing with to
detect gravitational waves we won by a
couple years
but they basically made it work well
enough that they
helped us triangulate that virgo virgo
yeah
there we go and so the adding virgo was
absolutely essential to get
a small enough place in the sky that we
could point to where it was and
compare with uh so it's two machines in
the us and one in italy and that gives
you enough data to
things happen so now you can not only
detect the gravitational wave but
actually look see the electromagnetic
wave from the
sort yeah and that one had i i
i'm going to skip on because i'm going
to be out of your time in a few minutes
probably you're going to kick me off
but we're having a good time we're
having a good time okay
but uh that had a feature which i'll say
in words and not show you the pretty
graphs
but uh that people have explained
phenomenologically what happens when two
neutron stars come together
and different models and the model
that's the
uh called a kilonova was was the model
that fits the data very well when we
look at all the different
frequencies down to the radio on the
signal from this neutron star merger
and uh and that has a feature that helps
us explain something maybe
you know one observation doesn't do it
but uh
one i think embarrassment for physics
that i knew about is that we have a
really hard time
explaining how the earth how when the
earth was created the heavy elements got
there like gold and platinum where'd
they come from
and because the the universe is made out
of hydrogen and helium and then we have
stars
and the stars uh work by fusion
and the fusion process eventually burns
out
and gravity causes them to collapse but
in that whole process you get to maybe
iron but not up to gold and platinum
so where did golden platinum come from
well in
terms of making the periodic table we
know that what people did typically
is take neutrons and scatter them off
some heavy
element and make a heavier one and name
it and we've learned what the periodic
table is but that's making them not
in nature and it turns out that if you
uh take these kind of neutron star
collisions which now we know exist
uh they make they're very much like
neutrons scattering in a lab to make uh
to make them that uh they are very
likely
we can't tell really on one event very
quantitatively the source of
the heavy materials like gold and
platinum that are in the earth
so what we observed is probably the
answer to
a long question that we've had in
physics
and so you found if i if i don't
remember the exact numbers but on these
neutron star collisions you can create
many times the mass of the earth in in
in gold
yeah if we show slide 11 it's
dramatically shows
oh you do yeah if you can bring up slide
11 love to uh what what is the number
how many uh uh i i i wrote it on there
it's
uh it's hundreds of earth masses i think
here it comes
yeah hundreds of hundred earth masses in
that one collision wow
okay and so of course that didn't
contribute to the earth but
that's true once in the past you can
imagine some of that got into the earth
so it's a it's a re-thinking of uh the
way in which the elements formed usually
just thinking of them as stars as
your furnace but now the collisions yeah
these nutrients may be a dominant
way certain elements are formed exactly
and we need more data
and there's also some unknowns in there
because there's some nuclear physics
that's rather complicated that
uh goes goes into that so anyway
where do you think this is all headed
then so that's what i'm going to show
you so i'm going to i want to show you
where we are
where we are today and i'll hand it
where we'll be tomorrow okay
yep i'll tell you what we're doing
absolutely today when i'm not busy
talking to you
yep uh if we go to slide
12 13.
okay slide 13 basically shows everything
we've done before the
pandemic turned us off okay okay
and so it goes uh and what it is is a
plot of the number of observed events
uh up the side and uh
time on the on the axis and the way we
do things is we ran those are
one o two o three means observational
run one
observational run two observational run
three and the way we run is we run
and then as i said because we're not
limited by nature we put in a bunch of
upgrades and changes maybe
you know improved laser or improved
optics or something
and then we run again for some period of
time and then we turn off and we
lick our wounds and we run again and so
we've had three
runs and you can see that in the first
run we saw the
actually three events the two that i
talked about before and then another one
then we made some improvements and we
saw eight events in our second
run and in the run that we just
terminated we ran for
i think 50 weeks uh we were going to run
one year but we
turned off slightly early and we saw 56
events
so we're down to one a week one week the
improvements that we're making now
uh when we turn back on which should
have been about a year from now
but are going to be maybe a year from
this last summer
but they're going to be longer because
it's just difficult to do the work we
have to do
and keep people at a distance and all
the things we're having to do now
so it may be a little bit longer uh
but what else so it will be better
by being able to get an event a day or
so where does that take us by the way
just sounds like very quickly one quick
thing on that on the 67
what fraction of those are black hole
murders 90 90 okay
yeah i'm going to show some differences
now so
uh as kind of the last thing that i
prepared and
uh so uh so let me say two things one is
we're working toward
0.405 and future detectors
and as i said we're not limited we're
limited maybe by
money and making it all work but this
this will continue to get to be a better
story
so you can do these things much more
accurately when you think about it in
the future
but if we look at the next slide it's
really where we are today
so we've taken these 67 events that we
have
and we've identified not the ones that
are black holes which gives us more
statistics
but the ones that that we call
exceptional events
that is the ones that look strange this
is fun uh
it's of course small statistics but it
gives us some sense of things so i'll
just show you
uh two examples already we got a handful
of these and that's
you know the non ninety percent uh first
we saw
we've seen black holes collide and we've
seen neutron stars collide
what i show on this plot is when neutron
stars collide
they should be in the distribution on
the left
they thought to be a certain range and
um black holes when they collide should
be
basically off the scale to the right
that you can't be that light and have
enough gravity to be a black hole
so there's a lower limit on a black hole
of three to five
times somewhere in that ballpark the
mass of our sun
yep well we found events that are in
between
so what does that mean does that mean
maybe our measurements aren't good
enough
maybe i can't tell yet but but here's an
event that's five sigma
above where we think a neutron star
should be
one of the items and uh well below
what it would be for a black hole so
what is it
maybe it's new maybe it's not uh but
these are fun so it's fun to play with
these
if we look at the next slide it shows i
think the next slide
is uh
this one here barry yeah
okay so now this is the next thing we've
seen this is a this is amazing this we
just
brought out a couple weeks ago and had a
little
news conference and stuff notice it
looks different than the
the the bringing that we saw before get
bigger and bigger it looks like just
says
oscillation this is an amazing event
it's
two very heavy black
if it's this we don't know two very
heavy black holes combining and making a
combined
mass of about 150 times the mass of our
sun
that's thought to be a non-uh
a region that we can't explain why there
would be black holes there
that is a region of more than 100 solar
masses
we believe these black holes we don't
believe the best story for where these
black holes that we've detected come
from
is always the fact that they came as the
final products
of the collapse of a star and you make a
black hole that way
but we're not sure they might have may
have been primordial or something else
but
we think it's hard to make black holes
that are too heavy here we see something
that's very heavy too heavy to explain
so we're not sure
the very next slide i compare it just to
just to clarify that so the guy
they're just going back to my own uh
memory of this stuff so if the
progenitor star is too big then when it
undergoes the collapse it actually just
blows itself again
it's just too unstable and so
so and we don't know exactly where that
is but we're well beyond we're
strong even seeing the heavy ones we've
seen it's very uncomfortable
like 65 65 or so solar masses is usually
the limit that people talk about
exactly and here where we started with
ones that are heavier than that and make
something that's a hundred and something
so
yeah we're talking about uh black holes
that are
considerably heavier could these black
holes have
a sequence of mergers well that
so so that's interesting so that would
mean they were created very early
yeah in the universe and we end in a
region where there's enough of them
around
that they did that or they primordial
that's why i'm saying the picture of
where these came from
is the next studies that we have to do
to do that you really like to get to
cosmological distances so you can see
how many are there
early far out so forth and that's what
we'll be able to do with more
uh more sensitivity it's not so much
more events like doing the higgs
but being able to pro become more
everything we do now is
very uh not very much redshift so it's
very much
uh non-cosmological and the big step in
a future detector i think is to do
cosmology with gravitational waves
if we look at this slide this next slide
let me just say it for a minute
then this shows this one uh that we see
these in between these show two
merging and making the next one the left
scale is the mass
and this is this strange event that we
saw
when i look at this funny shape we can
compare it with this ring down
shape on the bottom and it's
at the limit of where we can detect
anything because it's very low frequency
so we only see
this last piece so where i drew the
arrow
it points to something that looks like
that top picture if that's really the
picture
we can't fit it in the way we did the
earlier ones to einstein's equations
we're just seeing this
shape and so maybe this is a heavy black
hole
and that's what we're seeing or maybe
it's something else
so we we don't know and so
right now we're in this kind of fun at
least i think it's a fun game which is
looking at the peculiar
uh events that we have some of them may
pan
out to be new and interesting science
and some maybe he'll fade away i don't
know
well look i mean if you can find a
deviation from general relativity all
we've heard for the last 100 years is
einstein works einstein works everything
that came out of general relativity was
perfectly master observations and if you
can find the first
example that stands outside that
theoretical framework requiring some
modification
wow that would be uh i agree and
eventually we have to
do quantum gravity anyway so we have to
get beyond classical gravity
yeah no if you could uh find a way to
test ideas like string theory with uh
waves how how fun would that be yeah
exactly
i think we have to go we have to go to
black holes to do that probably
yeah no doubt um there are a couple of
non-physics questions i wanted to
end with but let me make sure is there
any other physics stuff that you want to
cover before
i think we're pretty much up to date
we're busy uh the last thing is we're
busy
actually conceiving of what a future
gravitational wave detector would look
like
yeah so we can keep improving ligo for
the next decade
and then we want to make one that's
bigger and better we're talking about
40 kilometers on an arm the europeans
are talking about going deep underground
we're talking about making them
cryogenic so they're cool and quiet
uh there's a lot of ideas that would be
40 40 kilometers that'd be 10 times
ligo right yeah the european one is the
one that i have in the slide here
and it has a lot of things that we don't
do yet so you can see there's a lot of
room for making big steps
they talk about going underground that's
much quieter
yeah they talk about using a triangle
that's
uh has the advantage that you can run
beams both clockwise and
counterclockwise and
do all kinds of cancellations which you
give sensitivity
they uh we talk about going to cold
temperatures that's a hard problem but
doable
and making it specialize in certain
frequency bands
so this just gives a sense without going
into many detail
that you can envision how to make much
much more sensitive
uh detectors as we project you know into
the
into what sort of time frame would you
imagine to build something like that
uh i we're trying to work
forgetting about governments and money
and so forth for a minute
i think technically we'd like to have it
on the same time frame
as the as they do a serious space
experiment which looks at a different
frequency band
so we can correlate those and that's
called lisa
and it's uh supposed to fly in about
2034.
2034. so in the period of 20 the
mid-2030s
we would like to have the best possible
earth bound detector as well
fantastic um so this has been incredibly
fascinating
there are two things that i just wanted
to touch on before we finish
here one is you're talking about work
that has required a tremendous amount of
international
collaboration to work you talked about
postdoc in germany who found the signal
you talked about the detector in italy
virgo that allows us to now triangulate
the signals and so forth
we have been passing through an unusual
political
era in which our standing in the world
has changed because of the
kinds of decisions that our government
has been making have you felt
any of the impact of that
in the international collaborations that
are central to the work that you guys
have been doing
well i think i think the the biggest
impact right now
immediately at this point is china
uh and that's on a very individual basis
we have a lot of uh
very very good students and postdocs in
the us that have come from china
they have visa problems now and so
and this now crosses not just
gravitational waves but i think
physics and science in general the the
extra problem of the chinese and the
attitude toward the chinese
the problems otherwise uh
which is uh is um
an attitude that's changed that's more
domestic
hasn't directly affected us in ligo
where our international collaboration
proceeds fine
uh we're stuck by a pandemic having to
use uh
zoom instead of meet together physically
when we again try to divide up
responsibilities to build we're not in a
stage where we're building
uh big things the next steps in ligo
actually have collaboration
and hardware that's being brought from
australia and the uk
uh as far as we can tell we're not we're
not suffering yet from the restrictions
of that
so personally ligo we're not affected
except for our students post-docs stuff
like that
uh but i think in general for the future
it'll get to us just like it gets to
anybody that's using any of the
collaborations that rely on on combined
facilities and
it's just look science doesn't have
boundaries it's not a national problem
it's a
universal problem we all teach the same
talk the same language whether it's you
about
entanglement or yeah or came on or me
about this it's a universal problem we
we don't have boundaries and they're
artificial
when they're made we scientists have
been pretty good at trying to work
around them
it's better if we can solve them and try
to work together
absolutely so final thing just to take
us back to the very first
thing that we spoke about you noted that
when you were 15 you were given
moby dick it wasn't the right book for
you at that moment
and kind of had this impact on your life
that was ultimately a good impact
you've done quite well with yourself
obviously
um but when you think about kids who
have some excitement about science per
se and in the classroom
they may not be getting the kind of
stimulation
that will make them want to pursue that
further any
any thoughts advice for you yeah
yeah yeah i escaped a big problem and
you escaped a big problem and that is
that
when you take kids at the age of five to
10 or whatever and you see them
they're incredibly curious about
everything around them
you know they ask you a question they're
a pest because they ask you too many
questions a young kid
and somehow in schooling we kill that
for the most part we even have an
expression called curiosity kill the cat
which to me
is the problem and says
curiosity is a bad thing curiosity is
the absolute heart
of the audience that you have asking you
questions
it's the heart of why i'm doing science
while you're doing science and we
somehow
managed to not be able to do a little
math and so forth and be able to do this
but that we somehow escaped having
curiosity killed i mean
if you ask what drives me the most it's
curiosity
and and we use the term curiosity driven
research but
it doesn't matter whether you're doing
something that's uh
maybe more directed than you or i do but
i think the
big thing is curiosity and the people
that
your audience is people that are curious
keep it up
try to answer those questions and let it
drive your life it's a wonderful human
attribute and we've done it wrong in
school where we've kind of
dissuaded you from having curiosity and
asking the questions and beating away at
it and so
my feeling is i i managed to escape that
you managed to escape the problem
and your i encourage your audience to
not let curiosity kill the cat be
something that runs their lives
yeah absolutely you know it's funny i've
never thought of that phrase literally
but as you think about it you recognize
just as you said it's such a bad
phrase it's the wrong connotation and
creativity
you know creativity is what makes us who
we are yeah absolutely
so i absolutely agree with it but thank
you barry so much for taking the time
out thank you
for having me with us and it's always a
pleasure talking to you i hope our paths
will cross in the real world
yeah hopefully in new york city yeah
that would be great so anyway thanks a
lot and we will be
so appreciate you joining us hello to
your wife i will do that
tracy who's probably listening right now
so
talk soon bye all right everybody that
was barry barish
nobel laureate in physics for
the ligo experiment first detection
direct detection of gravitational waves
and incredible achievement
and we heard directly from him the
journey that took him
from 15 year old boy putting down moby
dick
turning to science and then making this
great breakthrough confirming einstein's
ideas and now possibly being part
of work that will take us beyond
einstein the
events that bear is talking about at the
end that don't seem to fit in directly
to the
general relativity paradigm maybe it's a
measurement error maybe with refinement
everything that einstein said will work
but uh how amazing would it be if that
proves not to be
the case okay anyway let's now turn to
uh
a few questions before we wrap it up for
today
and i believe that i can
yeah it's big enough text that i can
read what's happening over here
so again any questions on any of that
what we discussed happy to go a little
bit further if you want to go in a
different direction that's okay too
um anonymous swimmer asks question for
brian if time is just another dimension
of space-time
then why does dark energy only act to
push apart space does dark energy also
create
time that is a that is a good question
i'm not exactly sure what the best
approach to answering that question is
but let me put it this way so
dark energy is energy that fills
space through time so at any given
moment of time
we imagine that dark energy is filling a
region of space maybe filling all of
space
and in that context dark energy gives
rise to a repulsive gravity that pushes
space
outward and thereby creates more
space that will exist at a later moment
in time
so we are doing a slicing of space time
into space at moments of time
in the description that we give when we
talk about repulsive gravity driving the
expansion of space
so it isn't that dark energy isn't
creating
more time there is time that
is part of our description it's just
that the way in which space changes
through time is the operative quantity
that we use to talk about the expansion
of the universe the expansion of space
and that language immediately does a
separation between space and time
so there is a deep connection between
space and time
as you noted we call it space time but
in this description of an expanding
universe we are looking at
space at successive moments in time so
it's a very particular slicing
of the whole space-time loaf into
all of space at a given moment in time
and that's the description that we
typically use but yes fundamentally it
is all deeply connected
um let's see um uh
tanzumil asks is it possible to trap a
photon
or a photon can only exist at the speed
of light yeah you can trap
photons in principle you can imagine
putting a photon in a
in a cage that has mirrors and then
photon is just bouncing around
any time the photon is between the edges
of the cage is traveling at the speed of
light it hits the mirror
and then you should really think about
what happens when light reflects off of
a mirror microscopically
photon is absorbed and re-emitted but
the photon
speed within the cavity will always be
equal to the speed
of light so the answer is somewhat in
between the two
ideas that you mentioned there's a ligo
question for barry
barry's gone i wonder if i am so bold as
to read the question and try to address
it i may not be able to address it
what is the physical limit of how we can
measure the expansion rate of the
universe aha
and it's changes from the big bang to
now using ligo or better
detector that i don't really know ligo's
role
in those kinds of measurements but those
kinds of measurements are being actively
pursued they've been pursued for decades
you know even in some sense edwin
hubble's initial
observations of preceding galaxies by
looking
at the spectra of the receding galaxies
you know how fast they're moving away if
you have some means of measuring their
distance then you know what their speed
was
at a given distance and that's what we
mean by the expansion
rate of the universe right when we talk
about the expansion rate of the universe
we don't just give a speed
we give a speed at a given spatial
separation
because the further apart things are the
faster they recede from each other more
space
moving apart means that the objects
themselves will move apart more quickly
so the number that we often quote is
something on the order of 70 kilometers
per second
per megaparsec right megaparser you know
parsec about three light years
megaparsec
about three million light years so at a
distance of roughly three million light
years things are receding at about 70
kilometers per second
and people are trying to refine those
measurements and there are long time
arguments
is the hubble parameter 68 kilometers
per second or megaparsec is it 72
kilometers per second per megaparsec
now people are still using more refined
measurements having some arguments over
the exact value
but i don't know that ligo as yet is a
deep part
of that particular measurement but if
if barrier here he might give a
different answer that's my answer not
barry's unfortunately um
philip asks i right now i'm sure we
are able to create a black hole first we
need a universe to be able to create a
black hole we have all the technology
now to make that happen
um well yeah in principle we could make
black holes
in fact some of you may know that the
large hadron collider
the machine that superseded the
superconducting super collider
that barry barris was deeply involved in
in texas
there was a illegal suit an injunction
was issued in fact
to not turn on the large hadron collider
for fear
that the large hadron collider would
create
black holes through the collisions of
particles because
black holes can be any size so barry was
talking about that first detection of
gravitational waves involving black
holes that were about 30 times
the mass of the sun right and then he
was talking about
these outlier events where the black
holes were like
beyond 65 solar masses 70 80 solar
masses coming together to yield
a combined black hole of 100 150 solar
masses but
you know if you take anything in the
world at all you take an orange
and you squeeze it down to a
sufficiently small size
you will have a black hole with the
weight not of the sun
but of an orange right einstein doesn't
declare that there's a
minimum mass necessary in principle if
you have a mechanism
to squeeze things down to a very small
size so the thought was that at the
large hadron collider
as protons collide with each other
you're cramming a lot of mass into a
very small size
maybe you will create a black hole
now some people worried about
creating a black hole after all black
holes have this reputation
for pulling everything and sucking in
the world around them the fact of the
matter is
black holes actually don't suck in
things more powerfully
than any object any other object of the
same mass so
if you have a solar mass black hole and
the sun they both
suck things in with the same
gravitational pull the only difference
is
you can get closer to the edge of a
black hole
that is you can get closer to the center
compared to getting close to the center
of the sun because the surface of the
sun gets in your way
a black hole is so much smaller that you
can approach the source of the gravity
at a closer distance that's really the
only difference between them
so if you create a black hole that has
you know
a mass of a few protons maybe you
shouldn't really
worry about in fact the math also shows
that they would disintegrate really
quickly
i guess the worry was that that little
black hole would pull in more material
and a kind of snowball effect
maybe would suck in geneva and after you
suck in geneva
maybe pull in the rest of the world this
was the worry
and it's not silly to worry about these
things if you're going to build a
machine that probes a new energy
domain you better make sure that you're
not going to destroy the universe in the
process i'm all for that
i'm i'm conservative when it comes to
destroying
the universe not cavalier but it isn't
to worry as it turns out the machine's
been running for a long time the
universe is still
here but you're right that in principle
we could have created a black hole in
fact
had we created a black hole it would
have been incredibly exciting
to answer phillip's question if that was
the name of the questioner
and unfortunately we've not created any
black holes at the large hadron collider
that's unfortunate because how
spectacular would it have been
to slam protons together create a little
black hole that then evaporates by
hawking radiation giving off the
radiation that stephen hawking
mathematically discovered should happen
when you have a black hole how great
would that have been
it hasn't happened so rather than it
being something to worry about
some people were again i'm not
denigrating the worry but once the
calculations show that you shouldn't
worry about it you should shift your
energy that's going into anxiety into
energy that goes into excitement
and indeed it would have been exciting
but as yet
we have not seen any evidence of black
holes at the large
hadron collider all right a few more
questions here before we call it a day
um
what do we have here uh
so homer asks you always say i guess you
is me you always say that distant points
diverge move apart greatly in time on
the space-time loaf
when one of them is moving any practical
example
to measure that well yeah absolutely
right i mean you may have followed
the work of the nobel prize winning
astronomers saul perlmutter and adam
reese who is part of our conversation
here
we should have saul part of this
conversation too i think you enjoyed
would enjoy listening to him brian
schmidt in australia the third member of
the
consortium that received the 2011 nobel
prize what did they win the nobel prize
for doing
exactly what you're asking they used
supernova
powerful stellar explosions happening in
distant galaxies
the explosions are so powerful that you
can see the light from the explosion
clear across the universe okay
so these are stellar beacons out there
in space
and by carefully measuring the
properties of the supernova explosions
the astronomers were able to measure
their speed of recession
and their distance and indeed they found
number one
that these distant stars in these
distant galaxies
are receding from us in exactly the way
that you recount in your question
they're diverging from us they're
receding from us at a speed that's
proportional
to how far away they are from us good
but they also found
that the rate at which they are receding
is speeding up over time not spitting up
because they're farther away at a given
distance
the expansion rate is getting larger the
hubble parameter
is getting bigger in time and that's the
so-called accelerated expansion
of the universe which was the big
shock in the late 1990s we're still
feeling the reverberations of that shock
as we
try to come up with refined explanations
of
why space is accelerating in its
expansion dark energy which we
was mentioned earlier that's our best
explanation today
but where'd the dark energy come from
and why does it have the particular
value that it does could it be in fact
that the strength of the dark energy
might
grow energetically in time what would
that mean
that would mean that not only are things
rushing away ever more quickly
but they would continue to do so
at an ever greater speed on into the
future
and if that were the case then we might
be facing what's known as the big rip
it could be that in the far future the
expansion rate of space is so
high that material structures
planets stars people atoms
they themselves might be blown apart by
the expansion of space within them
that's one possible end to the universe
and it all comes from careful
measurements of exactly
what you were asking about in the
question homer
points in space diverging through
explicit measurements determining how
quickly they're
diverging how quickly they are moving
apart from
themselves from other objects in space i
should say
okay ernest says do you trust relativity
i don't even know what that means ernest
i mean do i believe that the general
theory of relativity
has been observationally and
experimentally established
to be an accurate description of the
world yes i do
it's not a it's not a question of trust
i know we're just talking informally so
i don't mean to come down on you for
that language
but the reason why i have confidence is
the real
word that i'd use i've got confidence in
the general theory of relativity because
the math of general relativity makes
predictions about the world we go out
and measure the world
and the predictions are borne out and
our conversation with barry barish
is the pinnacle example of that einstein
writes papers
on gravitational waves back in 1916
1918. he himself was not really
convinced as barry noted 1930s he wrote
papers
that began to show that he was not
convinced that these things would be
real but other scientists as barry
mentioned in the 1950s came to the
conclusion that these really
are a mathematical prediction of the
general theory of relativity and then
people like joe weber and people then
who take
the torch in a far more productive
direction
to build ligo and advance ligo they find
the gravitational waves they find what
the math
predicts if you've never had the
experience
of doing a little calculation and then
looking out into the world
and seeing that the world follows the
pattern articulated in the mathematics
encourage you to try to have that
experience it can be a very simple one
just a ball rolling down an incline
plane if you want do the
mathematical calculation and just
measure the ball rolling down
and the fact that the motion of the ball
agrees with your mathematical
calculation
it's really thrilling now imagine that
happening with something that
nobody previously had ever seen happen
in the world we've all seen balls
roll down inclined planes but no one
before the first observation of a black
hole had seen
a black hole no one before the first
detection of gravitational waves had
seen
a gravitational wave so it's it's a
miraculous thing that the mathematics is
able to make these predictions about the
external world
and then we're able to confirm them so
that's not
trust it's confidence coming from
a mountain of experimental evidence
that's
why these ideas hold sway
in the field okay
so ernesto so fear make mind expanded
the black hole and we don't need another
never-ending story collapsed to lanava
ernesto i'm sorry man i
i've no idea what that means
i know what nada means that's another
way of saying
nothing i think but ernesto if there is
some
hidden message in that little question
you're gonna have to clarify i've got
no idea what in the world you're talking
about okay anyway onwards
um jamie how do we know for certain that
the age of the universe is 13.7 billion
years
isn't it possible if the universe has
been expanding at the speed of light for
a long time yeah so where does the
number come from 13.7
13.8 billion years it comes from a very
simple calculation which is this
as of today as i've recounted we know
that
space is expanding the distant galaxies
are all moving apart
so in your mind's eye picture that film
everything rushing apart
what we can do with the mathematics of
einstein's theory
is in essence wind the cosmic film
backward we can't literally do that but
mathematically we can do that
and as we wind the film backward
everything comes closer
and closer together galaxies come closer
and closer together they merge
ultimately get smaller and smaller
the universe gets hotter denser more
extreme and we can continue
winding this film all the way back to
the moment
when everything in the observable
universe is on top of everything else
when it's all squashed together into an
infinitesimal speck
and we can use our mathematical
understanding of this rewind to figure
out how many years
we'd have to do this rewinding and the
answer that comes out of the math
is about 13.8 billion years
now does that mean that the universe
began
13.8 billion years ago not necessarily
the universe could have had a
pre-history that
we may not know anything about that led
up to
this compressed state from which
running the film forward everything
emanated
there could have been a long prehistory
there could have been a whole sequence
of
cycles maybe of expansions and
contractions expansions and contractions
and we're just living through
the latest cycle so when we talk about
13.8 billion years
we should qualify by saying 13.8 billion
years
is the duration from when everything
that we now see was on top of everything
else but whether that moment was the
true beginning
of time beginning of the universe that's
the question that nobody knows
the answer to so jimmy yeah it's
certainly possible that things were
happening for a long time
before that if even the notion of before
which is a temporal notion does that
even make sense
could it be that time itself came into
existence
with the expansion with the big bang and
therefore this earlier
era we're biased into thinking in
temporal language temporal language but
maybe temporal language is not even the
right language to talk about it
that's a possibility too okay
so what do we have a few more what time
is it now it's almost five o'clock so
i'll wrap up in a
few minutes as um i'm uh i'm
i'm quite hungry today i need something
to eat
um all right so what do we have 11 music
do you think there could be ancient
civilizations that have that we have no
record of because they are millions and
millions of years ago civilization that
went extinct
yeah it's certainly it's only possible
it's hard to
rule things out i mean when you look at
the archaeological record there seems to
be
a fairly nice progression
in terms of the physiological
development
that we can plot out on you know
ketograms whatever they're called but
you can actually see
speciation happening so you know humans
or humanoid like entities you know
our history goes back generously a
couple million years
you know it could be millions and
millions of years before that that there
were civilizations
you know conceivably what's you know if
you want to go into those kind of crazy
well not crazy if you want to go into
those far out speculative ideas
you can say where we visited by some
alien species that may have
taken a look at planet earth and said ah
yeah they're up to single-celled
organisms or you know oh you know
they're up to
amphibians whatever but we're not that
interested in hanging around because
there's nobody to talk to yet
here on planet earth that yeah could
that have happened it could have
happened
i've seen no evidence that that has
happened so don't get me wrong
i'm not one of the people that talks
about area 51
in nevada okay these kinds of things
did not excite my curiosity at all
but that doesn't mean that there
couldn't have been
these kinds of visitations in the
ancient past
it just means that we don't have any
evidence that it happened
okay what do we have here um
um uh ernesto tried again
what i said is that when i have fear of
fail the thoughts of my brother and
sisters make expand the black hole
because all of us are increasing the
vacuum
boy it's a little clearer ernesto but
i'm still having a little
trouble um sorry i'm just not sure what
to make of that ernest i know that we're
having a bit of a communication issue
here so yeah so alex says yes an answer
to the previous question planet of the
apes you blew it up damn you yes
charlton heston on the beach sees the
half sunken
statue of liberty i should have
mentioned this one of my favorite films
if you haven't seen the original planet
of the apes
you gotta see it you know so charlton
heston on a planet that is ruled by
apes and it turned out that for the apes
the humans were the earlier civilization
and we ruined it apes took over and uh
turned it into at least something that
was still in existence um
okay anything else that i can find here
um
that strikes my fancy to end on here
um oh yeah how does this relate to
twister theory
so roger penrose pioneer twister theory
it's an alternate way of
analyzing gravity with a particular kind
of mathematical structure that
roger invented so i'm not going to go
down that at this late time
i don't really know enough about it
frankly to give you
a good enough explanation of what it is
avish crosstask sabine hassenfelder
talks about how string theorists get
lost in math and try to get the theory
to fit in
what do you think about this and should
be a new approach now look
let me let me put it this way we
physicists who are more theoretically
inclined
we do our analysis with the language of
mathematics and we use that mathematics
to powerful effect as we have seen even
here today
all of the work that barry spoke about
is within the context of the
mathematical framework
of einstein's general relativity all of
the work that he alluded to
in the discovery of the higgs boson is
in the framework
the mathematical framework of the
standard model of particle physics which
itself
makes use of the mathematical structures
of gauge theories which themselves
of league groups
and lee algebras and if we're talking in
mathematical terms making use of
vector bundles that are associated to
certain principle bundles that are
manufactured using the mathematical
structures of differential geometry
over the space-time manifold which
itself
is in the mathematical language a
hausdorff differentiable manifold with a
pseudo
romanian metric these are all
mathematical ideas which
then we have been able as a community
to shape and mold into theories of the
universe
which then make mathematical predictions
for things that we should
find that is this incredibly successful
rhythm of physics over the last few
hundred years
mathematical ideas describing the
universe
its patterns using particular
mathematical structures going out in the
world
measuring trying to find the predictions
of these mathematical ideas
and on the loop of progress
the journey of progress continues now we
are at an
interesting phase right now because we
have
been so successful in our
experimental ideas especially in
particle physics
that we have been encouraged to go
beyond
the things that we can test today with
today's level of technology so we are
as string theorists using a lot of
mathematics to analyze
how the world might be we're not lost
in the mathematics we know exactly where
we are
in the mathematics however we are
certainly
being guided more by the brilliant light
of
mathematical consistency mathematical
beauty
mathematical economy because our
experimental colleagues have not been
able to shine
an experimental light on the high energy
scales the short distance scales
on which the new physics of string
theory and unification becomes most
apparent
so we're doing what we can with the
tools that we have access to and the
most powerful tool that we have access
to
is mathematics so again
i would say that we're at an interesting
juncture
a lot of interesting mathematical ideas
on the table
a lot of people examining and analyzing
those mathematical ideas to see
what implications we can draw from them
ultimately these mathematical ideas need
to confront data and observation
that's why we hope there's going to be
another
accelerator built china is talking about
building the next accelerate that would
give us new data that would give us the
complementary illumination from
observation experiment that's why
barry and his many collaborators working
in gravitational
wave physics are talking about building
this very refined
version of an interferometer that might
be underground in the manner that that
barry was talking about shielding it
better building a space
version lisa of an interferometer
experiment because gravitational waves
when they get to a level
of refinement that we see happening may
then be an another
light of illumination on the mathematics
of unification and string theory so it's
all just to say
that yeah right now certain arenas of
cutting-edge physics
are being driven by mathematics it's not
that we're lost
in mathematics that's so silly it's that
right now
math is playing a more dominant role
until
the observation and experiments are able
to catch up
that is my assessment of the situation
okay guys with that i'm gonna call it a
day
here please join us again i think it's
going to be next week when we'll have
another one of these
mixed sessions of questions and answers
in conversation
again i'd love to hear your suggestions
and we are keeping a list of the kinds
of people
not the kinds of people you know the
people the names of the people that
you'd like
to have part of these conversations
going forward
and you should also note that barry
bearish has a master class at world
science u
so if you want to hear more i don't know
if it's been released yet it may be
so go check it out if not it will be
released quite soon
i know we are i believe that we have
scheduled a conversation with andrea
guezz
this year's nobel laureate in physics
that may be next week or the week after
or something like that
so don't hold me to any particular date
it will be happening soon oh i'm being
told october 28th
at noon is when we'll talk to andrea
guess so that will be fun
newly minted nobel laureate for her work
on
observations of the center of the galaxy
in black hole so join us then
but i we may have something between then
between now and then
so keep an eye out again if you want to
follow me in particular i'm on twitter
on facebook be green on twitter you can
follow the festival itself
on any of its social channels many of
you know about these events through
the announcement on twitter so those of
you who are here without that and want
to be alerted what's going on you can
join the world science festival
newsletter
or you can also sign up for our
twitter feed as well okay with that i'm
going to call it a day thanks for
joining us
and take care until next time so long